my name's Cathy Guthrie and I'm the
chair today may are first of all
romantic arrangements please ensure that
microphones are muted when you are not
speaking that you do not interrupt other
speakers members are reminded not to use
the messaging chat function during the
meeting unless it is to report a
pecuniary non-pecuniary interest or to
notify the chair that you wish to make a
proposal that if you are itting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave additionally
you will be invited to speak and ask
questions by the chair please await your
turn if members lose connection to the
meeting they must contact the member
support officer Mandy Smith as soon as
possible and we all have the phone
number I can repeat it if you haven't I
would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the Internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except whether
our confidential or exempt items if you
make a representation to the meeting you
will be deemed by the council to have
consented to being recorded by entering
this meeting as a speaker you are also
consenting to being recorded by the
council and to the possible use of those
sound recordings for webcasting and/or
training purposes the council members of
the public and press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded introductions as
follows and if you wish to say good
morning that would be lovely that's Emma
rich Belle who's the assistant manager
food safety and licensing good morning
everyone
we have naturally lived the legal good
morning
kay Saunders the licensing officer good
morning Karen Sayer governance officer
good morning and in the background we
have various other members of our
officers who are running this meeting
for and do you wish to be introduced
Robert Carmichael I'll say good morning
anyway chair
okay well I'll leave it that the others
are there running it in the background
we also have David Price who is also a
licensing officer and I think that's all
the people and Karen's say we've all
done that right we need to introduce and
formally ask the governance officer do a
roll call for the members so apologies
for absence and substitutions Thank You
chair we haven't received any apologies
members if you could reply with good
morning or present when I call out your
name please councillor Gerard Brewster
present councillor Paul Ekman Yan
present councillor Julie Flatman present
councillor Helen geek I believe she's
not here
councillor Cathy Guthrie
yes present councillor David Muller
present councillor penny Orton here
councillor Stephen Phillips again I
don't think he's here councillor Daniel
Pratt here and councillor andrew
stringer present thank you to receive
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary insurers are there any
declarations of interest councillor
Brewster no Cass lacking young
young do you have any declarations of
interest
I have melange oh sorry Thank You
councillor Flatman no chair I don't have
any councillor mullah none chair
councillor Orton no counselor prat non
and councillor stringer none so may we
have confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting which were held on the 7th of
February and its are there any points of
accuracy of the meeting so can I have a
proposal for those minutes please
happy to proposed here salamullah do I
have a seconder please happy to second
chair and the government's officer will
now take a roll call off the vote
Thank You chair members if you could
reply this time with four against or
abstain please councillor Brewster for
counter at pingyuan for councillor
Flatman for councillor Guthrie for
councillor Muller
councillor mullah for Thank You
councillor autumn or counselor prat yeah
for and councillor stringer or Thank You
chair that's carried as it as there
approved the minutes will be have been
confirmed and will be signed at the next
practicable opportunity to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme none
receive chair questions from councillors
none receive chair move on to the next
part of the agenda which is ml r19 for
hackney carriage fares review I will now
invite the licensing officer to
introduce this river committee please
and it's okay if you would like to give
your report and we will listen to that
now thank you
Thank You chair this report is to
consider objections received against the
revised table Affairs fixed for Hackney
carriages operating in the controlled
zone of the mid Suffolk District which
the Licensing and regulatory committee
approved for public consultation at the
meeting of the 7th of February 20 2000
us have undertaken the statutory public
consultation exercise as instructed by
the committee at the meeting of a 7th of
February 2020 the committee in
accordance with the 1976 Act has three
options to consider having had G regards
for objections received which have not
been withdrawn objections which have
been received are attached to this
report as Appendix C
and officer and officer comments to
those objections received are attached
to this report as appendix D option 1
that no change is necessary to the
revised table of phase fixed for Hackney
carriages operating in the controlled
zone of MIT Suffolk option 2 committee
if minded to modify the revised table of
fares fixed for Hackney carriages
operating in the controlled zone of the
mid Suffolk District option 3 that the
committee is minded to adopt the
alternative proposed to have attached to
this report as Appendix II having regard
to suggestions made in a single
representation received during the
consultation period Rekha made
recommendations that the committee
consider the three options are set out
in 2 and above the committee's are
following consideration of options 1 2 &
3 above to make recommendations to
cabinet on the revised table Affairs
attached as Appendix A or appendix II
that the revised table of fares be
adopted whether the committee is minded
to modify the table or not and/or that
the alternative proposed table of phase
is adopted and in accordance with
section 65 of the local government
miscellaneous provisions Act 1976
recommend a new day which is to be set
for the very table of phase to become
effective no later than 2 months after
the specified date of the first of June
2020 the reason for the decision is to
recommend adoption as a revised or
eternity table affairs for Hackney
carriages within the midst of a district
legal implications the Act doesn't set
out a specific right of appeal where the
council has adopted a maximum table of
phase 4 Hackney carriages
however the fair table may from time to
time be subject to judicial review
consultation and following the
prescribed notice requirements mitigate
the main risks Thank You chair
thank you so members I will go through
in order to ask if you have any points
that you would like to be clarified by
the officer councillor Brewster sorry
none at the moment madam chair Thank You
counselor Epping young I'd sure I'd like
to understand what the whether the index
a is the original proposed tariff that
we considered at the previous meeting
yes councillor Flatman nothing at
present chair councillor Mulla nothing
at present share councillor Martin um
yes chairman it doesn't actually relate
exactly to the paper but in light of the
government's announcement knowing masks
in public transport will there be any
consideration in putting that as part of
the recommendation that's not relevant
to this we're just actually discussing
the fares cancer often could Nigel do
luke confirm that for me please Thank
You chair I mean as I understand it
there is going to be legislation coming
in for wearing of masks on public
transport in any case I haven't seen the
legislation myself but I would presume
that it it would include using a fire
hydrant and taxi vehicles as well so so
there would be legislation covering that
and isn't really necessary to be
included in this back on that then
chairman can I ask that that is recorded
in the minutes well it can be recorded
in the minutes but that
not what we're discussing today but I
realize that but I think it's important
that we need to make sure that already
said it will be recorded in the minutes
Thank You councillor Pratt yeah just
just a little question it might just be
my my ignorance really but in the
comparison table I just wondered why mid
Suffolk district councillor have a cool
out or summons charge of five pounds
when the other councils don't apply that
charge I believe that was set by
councillors members when we first
introduced taxing meat Affairs David
Price may be able to confirm that
because I wasn't I wasn't there so I'll
pass you over to David good morning Jeff
yes in in at the beginning it was it was
felt that the dead mileage between the
taxi starting and getting to its exist
fair point
was it was needed to be able to give an
additional fare at that stage that's an
extra thank you thank you for the
question and thank you for the response
councillor stringer
yeah thank you chairs on actually on a
committee that decided the the five
pounds that's because we felt we were
rural and taxis may need to charge to
get to someone's house before they then
take them on the journey that's why that
ended up in there
I just wanted to not go back but just to
clarify so if the government then
insists that everyone in a taxi should
be wearing PPE the Hackney carriages
will not be able to charge for this
because it's not part of our tariff can
I just confirm that is the case
they'll have to just give it away for
free we're guessing the were discussing
the fares at the moment so because Nigel
could could Nigel just
assist me on this that we are just
discussing the fares we can bring this
up at a later date and I quite
understand your question in councillor
stringer and a game from councillor
often but Nigel could you just clarify
what we're discussing today please share
we are we are just discussing the you
know the table Affairs but if you like
me to clarify that it's not PPE that's
being required it's just to face
coverings and it's up to individuals to
to provide their own face coverings
being a scarf of a mask so there'll be
no requirement for taxi drivers to
provide than themselves thank you for
that well I'm I'm actually more
mystified than I was at the start
because string in hand I'm trying to
stick to that excuse me excuse me we've
already cleared it that we are
discussing fares yes this would be an
additional thing and I am NOT discussing
face masks PPE or anything else today
thank you so we'll move on if you have
another question for the officer please
make it apparently I don't right thank
you for that so we'll move on and in
fact we now open up for debate and any
other questions may come through in the
debate which we can certainly minute and
I approve that and welcome all due date
so councillor Brewster would you like to
comment on what we have before us today
please yes madam chair you know the the
Appendix A and Appendix A II I am
conscious that there has been some
difficulty certainly in still market of
getting taxis in the evenings and
certainly later in the evenings I've
been told by one driver that and in fact
fees for the evening one really there's
been a shortfall of drivers simply
because the the amount of money coming
into them at
is not worth being on the road for at
that time of night I don't know if we've
got any input to that but I think I
would like to see something a bit more
comparable to perhaps wanted two of the
other districts I wait to see what other
people wish to say on that and I'd take
note of what you're saying and if
possibly when we come round again if you
have some idea of how you might put
something forward but quite clearly this
is the debate and the same view so if
you can keep that and park that I've
made a note of it
councillor a ping young and we're not
actually using the windowpane for
conversations so you have a point to
make and also part of the debate free to
go please Thank You chair I just wanted
to clarify the what is the difference
between the call-out summons which we
are charging and no other council is and
and the understanding charge because my
understanding was once you once you
hired a cab and it was on its way to you
the the meter was running so I dare to
see the purpose of this call out or
summons charge was my first issue I know
one and hold your other issue and we'll
just get an answer to those as it flows
yes yes all yes and so could David
perhaps helpers on that place that point
and then we'll come back to miss Perkins
wrapping up
David so chair that was just done
meeting myself so the difference between
the standing charge and good because the
counts rapping wrong thought that they
meter started running a service could
you explain no no sorry
the meter should only start running at
when the passenger gets into the vehicle
and not when the taxi is traveling to
its pickup point that would be the first
point and this is the the second point
in the dead mileage that called out on
something child who is an expert to
mitigate the distance traveled thank you
for that David so cancer rapping young
further pot party fuel to great please
please continue thank you
Thank You chair well I want to endorse
the comments from councillor Brewster I
think that particularly in snow market
that is a very important issue and I'll
wait for further comment from others but
I would have to means about what we do
in terms of charging for that particular
tariff as well as I
I also want to be clear that the
proposals in Appendix II generally
reflect the input that we had from from
the console team that submitted years
okay could you just confirm that for
councillor wrecking young please yes
that is correct
the alternative does reflect the one
representation that we see it thank you
for that thank you
and so councillor Flatman and so to
understand we have only had one taxi
firm or driver come back to us on this
yes that's correct
well I just I've emphasized what I'm
councillor Bruce to do it must be worth
your mark why
to go out in the evening but I find it
hard that to believe that taxi drivers
haven't come back to us on this because
anyway I'll leave it for now chair thank
you thank you for that
councillor mullah tea chair I would like
to agree with actually caster Brewster
and counter opinion my own personal
experiences in snow market that is
actually sometimes very difficult to get
hold of a taxi during the evening and I
know of other people who've actually
booked a taxi in stock market and the
taxi hasn't turned up so I think that
the the article we did have for the
person that was saying about the night
taxis I would tend to sort of agree with
actually thank you councillor often yes
I hope I've got the right forum table up
it appears that you're not proposing a
call-out charge in Baber whereas you are
in book and I just wonder bearing in
mind that the two districts are very
neighboring to each other and it's more
than likely that somebody could while
easy booked a taxi in Baber to go into
Stowe market and vice-versa
is that not a complication okay could
you respond to that David during the
Bebo could you just comment on the baby
one while they don't have it thank you
Jeff in answer to the councillors
question Barbara have never heard her
call out and summoning in charge so to
add one to it as the tariff charges were
quite high anyway and more comparable to
the rest of the other districts within
Suffolk that's why it's not them
councillor Olson do you require any
further comment at this stage I could
just add that from the drivers that I've
spoken to I don't say sorry I don't
think that many of them actually use
that call-out charge oh that's
interesting um I was more concerned
about people you know having to book a
taxi to go home say from stro market
into why do you know bill Dustin and
then being asked for a call-out charge
mm good point penny but I'm sure the
others will take it up and it'll
continue in the debate have you any
further comments to make at the stage
no thank you and councillor Pratt please
yeah just a just a quick follow on
really from my last question about the
summons calls and does that apply within
urban areas such as Stowe Market and I
or does it only apply if the taxi driver
has to drive out into a rural area to
pick up the passenger drive a discretion
okay and councillor string there please
yeah on that just going back to that
point of discretionary charges it's it's
only there to allow the taxi company to
charge it if they wish it's not and and
it's and it's you know and Penny's point
that what if someone lived in Stowe
market and they hired a taxi from Hadley
they wouldn't charge you know well they
probably wouldn't come and pick you up
all the way to Stoke market for the
standard fare anyway so they probably
would decline the business so there's
that there's that element of the market
will drive this out
I hear it's not being used that often
but it is there to try and give some
certainty to those that are in rural
areas that there can be a charge to get
out to you because over the standard
fare some taxis were denying coming to
because they weren't able to make it pay
just I just want some assurances from
the officers that we we've had this
quite lengthy sort of
paracin about physically the metering of
the thing and actually have some
sympathy with that do we have an
instance in mid Suffolk where because of
how we levy our tariffs have different
meters running at different rates and
getting different results for the same
journey not not that I'm aware of cancer
stirring if that shouldn't happen
because our tariff is quite straight
forward and the the chaps that fit the
tariffs into the meters all have the
same thing it should all it should all
be the same we've not received any
complaints that it isn't right okay and
we've not prosecuted anyone for not
having the correct tariff because the
this this document that we got could
actually lead to pinion operators being
prosecuted because they're getting to
the same point but actually with
different costs to the person the only
issue I had with that document was that
that person was suggesting that everyone
hires a taxi and asks them how many
miles and that's not what you normally
ask the taxi driver you normally ask to
take over how much is it likely to cost
me he sees what you normally yeah we
asked ask a taxi driver but any or you
know and we tend to measure this is
where it gets very confusing miles per
hour is actually also confusing Imperial
and metric measurement in the same
calculation because ours are a metric
measurement so you it's very confusing
anyway so I just want to make sure that
we didn't have that disparity here we we
don't because we don't with our our
faces are out quite clearly we don't
have it's 50% of the above 25% of this
it's quite clear what the tariff is and
and with as touchwood we've not had any
problems we've not prosecuted anybody
okay I just wanted to double check that
we weren't falling into those traps not
thank you for that well that sort of
then leaves me as telling Charlie to
sort of us a comment and all the
comments that have been made and
discussions are very valid and I take
them on board particularly with many of
the members representing all being in
stone market and indeed with councillors
stringer I can't remember that that's an
age thing whether I was actually on that
committee with that five pound but I do
see way he was coming from with that
explanation along with David Price about
that it was there to get to a rural
location and I was going to ask because
Bebo don't have that problem or or don't
have that issue that does they burr have
problems getting late-night back since
David J not that I'm aware of now so as
part of the debate our members
particularly those who've mentioned this
five pound charge are they thinking that
if it was removed and this will come
through in a more of a debate in a
minute I'm sure if they were removed do
they think that taxi drivers would be
more inclined to be available for
service so I just posed that question so
if we can move on again to go background
to people's thinking a little more
councillor Brewster can we go back to
you please and thank you madam chairman
yeah I'm just looking at the comparison
sheet at the moment it's it's not
perhaps easy to work out when we see
that Baber are charging 320 for the
first 400 we are charging 340 for the
first 781 yards and that makes it not
very easy to to calculate the difference
between the two the running Marr was
just certainly way
under @one 158 are running my land baby
are one pound sixty running mile hence I
presume why we were increasing or
suggested on on appendix a to increase
to 160 there's there's quite an
interesting fact I think whereas on the
alternative the running model would be
one pounds eighty in keeping in or more
in line with what the objector suggested
but it is more the nitrates that
concerned me I think certainly as far as
Mustafa and certainly still market are
concerned I don't know if it is it
possible to increase the nitrate without
increasing the the day tariff because
I'm conscious that obviously people have
got to book these taxes and go into the
taxes in an affordable way as well so
there is a I think there was a balance
here to be made and I'm just wondering
how to how to make it at the moment okay
could you respond to cancer Bruce's
query on that please
sorry on the alternative proposed cap we
have increased the nitrate as well if
you go along to the blue section a
happily if we have increased it so that
the running mile on the alternative is
220 as opposed to the proposed original
proposed which was 189
and the first mole increased to 5.40
from five pound 20 okay thank you for
that k yeah and I think the point that
councillor Brewster has made there is it
is very difficult to compare like with
like when there are slightly different
running miles and all sorts of things
involved so we move on councillor effing
young if people can think of what they
might be liking to to recommend you know
as we're going forward so counselor
Epping young have you got any further
comments to make please I thank you
chair yes I do I think that what we
ought to be doing mid the alternative
proposed tariff in fact I think is to
bring it in line with the Baber one
would be my proposal I don't understand
actually why when we're doing these
setting these rates we are not using
whole number proportions of of the of
the mile which for me makes everything
horribly more complicated than it
probably needs to be which I think you
know I can see that the guys in maybe
I've tried to do but not entirely
successfully I have to say because for
example if if I was looking at the flag
right and then I would probably take you
know 440 yards to being a quarter and
which is a purple of proper proportion
of the 717 hundred and sixty yards
whereas on the Ono on the one mile they
have 110 yards which works quite well so
I would propose that we do something
along those lines and I think that would
then begin to have a the kind of effect
that we're thinking about for the for
the night right because I think that if
we don't sort the nitrate out then we
will continue to see here difficulties
with having taxis available
in in in the nighttime in in still
market for example and if I go to along
those lines if I go to Appendix II then
I mean I would suggest that we agree
with the console T that we we remove we
remove the call-out chart but I would
also like to see a more straightforward
harmonization of the charge for
additional passengers it seems to me
just too many differents staggers and I
would suggest that we just have a 50 P
chart for every passenger above 2 and
then that's kind of very straightforward
and I don't really understand the
nominal charge for for luggage I mean
I've traveled all over Europe and I
don't see the point of 23 either we make
a sensible charge or we scrap it and
those are all the comments I have at
this stage Thank You chair thank you for
that cat strapping y'all I just have a
question possibly for Nigel and Kay on
on that basis
because at the moment we have the
options before us if we would have to go
or if we are minded if members are
minded to go along the baby route and so
on would we have to reconvene with
further suggestions is my question and
the other thing is I hear what counts
rapping young that's been saying and
I've sort of been pulling my hair out
with it as well and the documents that
we had for national tariff troubles
actually does show how difficult this is
and also if we go along suggesting the
baby route which members may well want
to do that or something different I
don't know we've got to get to that
point does that mean that all the all
the machines have to be changed or
something like that or is it just a
matter of altering the yardage and so on
can somebody help me on that please yeah
sorry chair I was just comparing the
proposed favored one and to our
alternative proposed and we are still we
are giving more on our alternative the
babies proposed the trouble with
compared meat babies there are one that
they've got at the moment is the one
where they've gone down the routes a 50%
of this 50% of that so it's been very
difficult to give a proposed one on the
because the one they've got has not been
read it can't be read as one thing it
sounds a bit complicated I know and yes
if we if you did suggest something else
it would take some time we'd have to go
away and work it out and would it then
have to go back out for consultation
again I believe not David can you just
get there Thank You chair know what you
decide today chair to modify the table
Affairs is how you want to set it out it
won't have to go out to consultation
again okay and just as sort of part of
the deal would the councillors have
obviously said they've spoken to taxi
drivers and it was good that we had
somebody to to put him writing what it
was and I just wonder that if we change
it radically to go to something else
whether that's going to cause problems
but we'll come back to that as week if
we may so um councillor Flatman would
you like to pass further comment please
yes um I totally agree we need to assume
a more simple way of having these
calculations but the other thing I just
wanted to ask the officers is this the
new rate that paper have just decided
because I know it's coming to cabinet
their cabinet very soon is this the new
race that they have decided recently no
no it's not it has bet their meeting is
next week and then it will go to cabinet
ah right so I'm still proposed yeah so
that would have been handy if we you
know if we're going to try and keep it
fairly the same that would have been
handy them sort of synchronised at the
same time really
crash okay sorry ciao I'm just thinking
that if we decide something today
and then there's is totally different
and they go higher then you know we
could have rounded this all up in one
well not necessarily we are two separate
councils and were you know we've had
this on the table yes you know if you'd
wanted it to be a joint thing then it
should have been recommended that we do
a joint thing but we're not are we we've
got totally I have been working on this
with what we did at the last meeting you
know that was the recommendation at that
time without any further input from taxi
drivers and so I'm not quite sure that
we need to be totally in alignment with
them but that's for members to decide
and you to decide
thanks chair yeah councillor Muller
Thank You chair I totally agree with
really what the Brewster was saying and
also some extent what counter at neon
was saying but my own thoughts on this
of having so else he looked at this in
some detail I'm sort of moving more in
favor of the alternative proposed tariff
because I certainly think this addresses
the nitrate which seems to be a major
concern so that's really what the way on
sore thinking at the moment on that
chair can we have people sort of
thinking and putting a proposal in the
conversation box as it's moving forward
because that sounds a good suggestion
from your thought I'm grateful for that
I think it's here and can you just put
that in the windowpane if you would
please yeah thank you
and as that sorry cats are often just
before I come to you do I have a
seconder for that for the alternative
suggestion at this stage please
we'll put a seconder in the box manager
so that's your good self is it counselor
Brewster it is yeah
please if you would thank you and then I
would come on
- counselor button for further
conversation and debate if you would
please oh yeah I'd like to go back to
the call-out charge particularly under
the nitrate I am a bit concerned that
would that deter particularly young
people and dare I say young women being
put off actually taking a night taxi you
know with that extra charge it's there
any way we can ask the officer is it
made clear that this is a a charge that
may not be yeah yes Kathy arm it is on
it's actually on the tower sheet which
drivers should have on display in the
vehicles but does it say that it's it's
it's discretionary discretionary in that
case I can see no reason to include it
and on the alternative we've got it
included haven't we can you put the
alternative sheet up for us please
so if members would like to sort of
focus on that and can we alter the
alternative sheet to do that okay if
that's the proposal that the proposer in
the second day come to and and I have to
listen to other members first before we
come to that decision is that possible
David what does it have to be accepted
in its form there you can order the
propose to alternate if you wish to
thank you for that
so moving on then councillor Pratt how
do you feel with what's being suggested
at the moment yeah well my concerns a
running kind of in line with Penny's
actually the the proposal I take it is
to is to put the nitrates up but this
may indeed put some people off from
using the taxi and we've got to and I
understand that there's a need for taxi
drivers to to make a living and you know
for them to be an incentive to actually
go out and work at nighttime but we've
got to consider you know how many people
can afford the increase and sort of make
a balance I think a little bit there so
with that comment if I go back to the
proposer in the second of it where you
have to hear from councillor string at
first but with your comment that you've
just made there if the five pounds was
removed but the rates put up on the
alternative would that satisfy your
concerns a little better um because the
five-pound then comes off doesn't it the
five pounds could come off I think I
think my concerns are if we raise the
tariffs
across across the board you know
independent of how many miles were doing
we're gonna we're gonna hike the fares
up this might actually squeeze the
number of people that can afford to use
the taxis so I think I don't know this
this sort of leaves more questions than
it than it sort of answers to me but I
do think we've got to find that balance
between putting the fares up to give the
taxi drivers better level of pay but by
actually not then constricting the
market for for taxis because because
then most people can't afford to use
them I don't know if you kind of get the
spirit of homespun to say absolutely
absolutely absolutely
Thanks so can people not put things in
the conversation table please that's
just for proposals and second as I'll
come back to you
councillor often we don't use the window
pane can I come excuse me chairman I
thought I could put an amendment to what
was being proposed well was it is what I
have done we'll come on to councillor
stringer no we're not using the window
pane I would come back to here I'm going
to come back to everybody to ask for
amendments if you don't mind
councillor stringer can I have your
further comments yes of course I I would
be perfectly happy to go with the
alternative proposed tariff knowing what
in its entirety knowing what is likely
to come forward on other matters which
will change the affordability in the
future but we really must keep the
call-out summons charge it is
discretionary if you walk up to a taxi
and you see that tariff on there you
can't charge it you you already there
you haven't had to summons it it is
about that very issue that penny
vocalized where you don't get perhaps
vulnerable vulnerable people at night
trapped if you are out here where we
live we are six and a half miles away
from any hackney carriage
which they are not going to drive all
the way out here to driver story or
anywhere else or somewhere late at night
for six quid they're not going to do it
they're not you're gonna come here for
six quid them able to have a call-out
summons charge which is discretionary it
means it gives them greater range to
come out before the taxi fare starts
it's empowering people to be moved not
excluding people so I would urge that we
go for the alternative proposed tariff
which fixes some of the nighttime issues
but keeping that summons charge in for
those that are vulnerable in rural areas
thank you for that councillor stringer
so we've all had had comment on that and
so at the moment we have a proposal and
a seconder to take the alternative
recommendation as is so can I ask the
monitoring officer to take a vote on
what we have on the table at present
please Karen thank you chair would you
like me to read out the proposal on the
table yes are we all clear if you would
read it out then we all will be clear
please yes thank you okay the proposal
on the table is that the licensing and
regulatory committee recommends to
cabinet that the revised table Affairs
attached as Appendix II sorry the
alternative proposed table affairs and
subsidy be adopted but we also need a
second proposal regarding setting the
date for the Affairs to become effective
so we are we're just going to vote on
number on um proposal one for now on the
proposal for say so we're voting on the
proposal that the alternative proposed
table Affairs attached as Appendix II be
adopted and that's recommendation to
cabinet
if you could and reply with four against
or abstain please councillor Brewster
for Spain councillor flapman for
councillor Guthrie for councillor moolah
for councillor Otton I wish to make an
amendment to the proposal to remove the
call-out charge counselor not councillor
legal officer Nigel we can't be doing
that at the moment we have a proposal
and a seconder and I'm going through can
you confirm what I'm doing is correct
please yes that's correct yeah we have a
we've had a motion we've had a seconded
and we're voting on that on that motion
thank you so can Karen go back to ask
councillor Otten if she's fought against
or abstaining against against councillor
Pratt's abstain and councillor stringer
for thank you that's carried by five
votes to one with two abstentions thank
you for that and Nigel could you just
explain why there wasn't an amendment to
the proposal that we had and that what
we were doing was legally correct please
um because someone had made a valid
proposal and it had been seconded it can
be opened for that person to amend their
their proposal but in this case it was
proceeded with with Adam that proposal
as has originally stated thank you for
that
so we now move on to the second part
which is when we need that to be
validated by s'okay
can you just make your suggestions on
that please it will have to be it has to
be months from the date which is the
first of June and it will have to be
after cabinet which is the 6th of July
so we could say sorry that the date of
cabinet is the 6th of July which is a
Monday is it yes that's right
and we're normal period to implement or
to arrange for implementation of such
changes it will it will take it will
take some time because they will all
have time for their meters calibrated
again with the new with a new tariff art
if it's effective but they can they
don't have to have it done by that day
it's the date where it can become faked
if then they can then work on getting
the need to happen so what would be a
reasonable date would you suggest I
would give them probably if we can give
them three weeks after that that's
nearly the two months then isn't it yeah
so what date would that be then I have
set my calendar and everything down we
just get it ok can I help you yeah I'm
just gonna 3 weeks from the 6th of July
is Monday the 27th of July yep I'm happy
I'm happy that members so if I just run
through it could Karen just run through
members to ask if the date is suitable
please okay so the proposal is that the
new date to be set for the very table
Affairs become effective would be Monday
the 27th of July if I could just check
with everybody that you agree with that
councillor Brewster yes I certainly I
agree with that
cancer at Penn Yan agree cancer flapman
yes I agree
councillor Guthrie councillor Muller yes
I agree
councillor Otton agree um councillor
Pratt yes I agree
AB causa stringer agree thank you that's
that's carried can I thank everyone for
a very useful and lively debate on and
thank you for arranging it from the
officers it isn't easy when they do this
remotely and I do thank everyone and now
close the meeting thank you very much
indeed
Thank You Gabby thank you
[Music]
you